pour cet agriculteur la moisson du blé
va durer jusqu'à 22h les règles en
matière d'irrigation sont très strictes
quand les cours d'eau sont en situation
d' alerte elle sera réduite à trois
jours en cas de seuils d'alert de à jour
voire interdite si la crise est réelle
c'était le 20 juin dernier
trois semaines plus tard le maïs arrive
au stade où l'irrigation est
indispensable à son développement
les irrigants qui pompe dans la nappe de
beauce ont un quota à gérer ceux qui
s'approvisionnent en rivière sont de
plus en plus rares les seules choses qui
sont irriguées en rivière sont le maïs
et jeu direct sur le département il n'y
a peu de surfaces de maïs il y en a
quelques-uns
agriculteur qui arrose du maïs en
rivière mais ça ne concerne que peu de
personnes le loir traverse presque une
centaine de localités d'eure-et-loir une
partie est en situation de crise l'autre
d' alerte pour le président du syndicat
du loir situation préoccupante mais
gérable pour l'instant les bagages
évidemment c'est un inconvénient pour la
continuité écologique c'est aussi un
inconvénient pour la libre circulation
des poissons mais l'été on est bien
content d'avoir des ménages pour revenir
l'envoyer au lieu de faire 6 7 m de
largeur à court d'eau d'un mètre de
large et 8 sur 20 cm de haut pour la
petite venise de beauce l'état du loir
n'est pas un souci et le soleil un atout
ça absolument pas d'impact peut-être que
sa basse un petit peu notre niveau faut
qu'on fasse attention au fond de notre
base de nos bateaux mais sinon qu'un
problème puisqu'on est sur des canaux de
la ville et on a une très petite partie
sur la rivière une belle météo ces
touristes sarthois ne vont pas s'en
plaindre le temps idéal pour profiter
agréablement d'une balade en canot
m